and then once you decide hey i'm gonna
uh
go do this again and go bash my head
against the wall and build another
company
uh did you have an idea as to what you
wanted to build or did you kind of make
the decision
uh let me build a company and then i'll
go find what idea i want to work on
um is really interesting this the
genesis story of 5 spin is completely
different than
like bottle of chardonnay and hey this
is a great idea
of hyperwallet um because i did have the
benefit of 18 years in the industry
so i called phi span a very intentional
business
i literally sat in my basement for a
year
thinking about different business ideas
because this is the one truth about
about founders if you would have asked
me in 2012
if i would start another company let
alone a financial services company
i would tell you only an idiot would
start a payments company
and only like you know a super idiot
would try and do this again
but you know we have a very very
selective memory and all the highs and
lows of running a business
you forget all the terrible lows when
you want to shoot yourself in the head
and you only remember all those great
times right
so but but feisman is very very
intentional
and i certainly took some of the
market observations from the hyper wall
at time
and a couple things were one that all
the hype in financial services
is in the retail side because that's
what everybody know you
know what it's like for you to use a
credit card or for you to use apple pay
right you know when you get irritated
about
you know your bank's online banking um
so that's where all the hype is a lot of
the attention but i
i really believe that there's huge
opportunities to make the world better
for
businesses um and the second thing i
knew
being an intentional start to fi span
was i didn't want to
compete against banks i fundamentally
had this
thesis that banks have superior payments
products superior cash management
services
superior loans because they have a lower
cost of capital like just
you know just think about the
fundamental underlying
attributes but they have reals really
really
struggle with you know that
quote-unquote delightful user experience
um so i literally sat there and i was
like you know there is there an
opportunity to introduce a
company and a business model into the
market that's sort of the opposite of
plans
where you're not aggregating banks for
third parties to own the customers
you're you're aggregating the end points
to allow
banks to better service their customers
so
that's the genesis story of phi span a
forgot the bad times
uh b had enough um you just wanted to do
it again
and see there was just so much
opportunity yeah and so this is a really
um interesting uh kind of framework you
provided of like there's plenty of
people out there who said hey
we're going to aggregate all the banks
and then allow the third parties to have
that relationship with the customer
you essentially are doing something
opposite right kind of taking the
uh the thing that everyone sees value in
and it's kind of been funding for a
while
and you flipped it why was that where
you wanted to go did you have kind of a
contrarian view saying that you know the
other people just don't see this
opportunity
uh was it a skill set or an experience
that you had but like how
did you identify that where maybe others
haven't spent a lot of time
uh well so there were some actual um
data points conversations with cfos and
treasurers back in my hyperwallet day
where what hyperwallet had done yes with
this
fantastic low-cost mass b2c service
but and we'd exposed ourselves through
apis to be in the cool kids club
but we've done one more thing which is
our engineers had
integrated our products and our apis
into our customers business system of
record these are big publicly traded
billion dollar companies
and that fact engendered a lot of love
and when i would go back and talk
to my customers they would say hey can
you provide us b2b payment services
can you provide us with cash management
services can you provide us with foreign
exchange
and i feel like why i'm just this tiny
little
under capitalized company why would you
even offer me and so
what they'd said is look i'm highly
banked
but what my banks offer me is a file
spec and now i need to go out and hire
someone to integrate it with my
workflows
and then i have a separate process and
then my internal controls are shot and
then i have an
additional audit cost um so
that was the specific
insight right it wasn't like i decided
it's
very clever of a contrarian view to the
market it was that there was
sufficient pain points by by corporates
that they were willing to engage with
third parties
for like fund what i call fundamental
transactional services
and so like quite frankly it was just
opportunistic i thought
look um i don't i don't want to build
something from scratch
but if i can arm banks to really service
that
need that's better for the customer
better for the banks
yeah that makes a lot of sense and so
talk a little bit about
kind of what was the first product you
built and kind of what is that
product or product suite look like today
yeah
so fundamentally what we like to say at
five spent
we bring business banking into the
customer context
and what we mean by that is like from
the customer's perspective it's about
jobs to be done
not a bank product to be used right so
i want to keep current with my overseas
customers
i don't want to send a wire right i want
to forecast my cash
i don't want to log into online banking
to view my balances
so in practice what we do is we embed
commercial banking services within other
applications
and the first and most important
experience
is embedding inside accounting and erp
applications
so we bring those bank services in
context
easiest way to think of it is by example
i'm inside my erp i've gone through my
workflow to approve a vendor invoice
i just want to click and have this
vendor invoice paid
i don't want to care whether it's like
ach check print
wire right i just click it's going to be
paid i know which
bank account is going to be out of
tomorrow when all like the magic has
happened
that object is going to be automatically
updated in my erp
all the track and trace information is
there
open banking apis you know host to host
connectivity
can make that all happen making that all
happen seamlessly without the customer
worrying about it
is what we do